i thought this was also pretty uh
revealing
yesterday morning yeah august 26th at uh
right right before 8 a.m
this was tweeted out by the sergeant
major of the army michael grinston i
think we have this tweet from him um
right before the attack okay now in
fairness this was this was before the
attack
like an hour before
here's what the sergeant major of the
army michael grinston tweeted he said
diversity is a number do you have people
that don't look or think like you in the
room inclusion is listening and valuing
those people
women hashtag women's equality day
reminds us we're smarter and more lethal
when we come together as an inclusive
cohesive team our values demand it so
this is what the army this is what the
top brass the people in charge of our
military were worried about yesterday
while terrorists were strapping suicide
vests onto their bodies and heading to
the airport to kill 13 uh of of our own
guys
that this is what they were focused on
is celebrating women's equality day
claiming that we're really you're we're
more lethal by being inclusive
with women in the army they make us more
lethal
now you want to claim that makes us a
more tolerant army then go ahead but
the point of the army is not to be
tolerant
it is to not tolerate certain things
like our enemies who wish us harm
but now the claim is that actually we're
more we are more deadly and fierce
and formidable fighting force if we're
inclusive and tolerant we've got a lot
of estrogen pumping through the ranks
how so
show me the the science on that i'd like
to see some studies on that
that show that uh the fighting units
with women are more deadly
so that defies all common sense
and there's no evidence of that
whatsoever and no reason to think that
it's true
but this is what our military is focused
on
and that's one of the points that i was
making yesterday in the backstage and
i've been making now for the last couple
of weeks
that i i don't think uh
the united states should be in the
business of building empires overseas or
nation building or
pursuing
imperial ambitions
i don't think that the united states
should be doing that
um our founding fathers certainly never
imagined that for the united states
never wanted that
but
even if i could go along with that in
theory even if in theory i could agree
that
there's
that it's a good idea
for us to become an empire and to expand
our reach across the globe
the problem is we're not operating in
theory we're operating in reality
and in reality the people who are
running the empire are these kinds of
people
and this is the influence that they're
extending across the globe
so if you like the idea of empire
building in theory
what i would say is take it out of
theory and put it in reality do you want
these people
to be the ones building the american
empire because they're the ones doing it
uh and speaking of these people who are
in charge of the american empire nancy
pelosi in the midst of the crisis in
afghanistan yesterday she got this was
after the attack she got in front of
cameras and uh and this is what she was
talking about
here we are 101 years later
women in positions of high
responsibility
but an attack
on the by the right to vote that is
happening in our country
a few days ago on tuesday in the house
of representatives under the leadership
of terry sewell a woman from selma
alabama we passed the john lewis voting
rights enhancement act
to offset the damage that the courts are
doing to the right to vote and in in
doing so we also need the senate to pass
it and to pass h.r 1 which is
legislation to overturn the voter
suppression laws that are being enacted
across the country
not only to suppress the vote
but to nullify the vote so we have
important work to do we have important
work to do
i when i saw that clip yesterday i
actually did kind of a double take
because she
i kind of
clued in when she said there was an
attack
on the right to vote
is after the deadliest day after she she
knew that we just suffered the deadliest
day in afghanistan for our military in a
decade and she's out there talking about
the entirely fictional
attack on the right to vote
again get rid of biden and these people
are still in charge
another word of warning again
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated